a package of wide-ranging criminal
justice reforms is one step closer to
becoming law after years of negotiations
the Senate approved the first step act
87 to 12 late last night the house is
expected to pass it later this week and
then send it on to the president Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with a look at
what this bill could actually do Nancy
good morning to you good morning and
President Trump said last night in a
tweet that he looks forward to signing
this bill perhaps later this week it
represents a major bipartisan win for
his administration it's called the
first-step Act and it is a comprehensive
piece of legislation that aims to
address overcrowding in prisons while
making the system fairer for nonviolent
drug offenders it for example eases the
three-strikes rule by reducing a
mandatory life sentence for some drug
offenders down to 25 years the bill also
improves early release opportunities and
expands job training for inmates
lawmakers across the political spectrum
credit the president's son-in-law Jared
Kushner for pushing criminal justice
reform for the past year and for
lobbying tough on crime Republicans to
support this bill the first step act
however is just that a first step right
now it only affects federal prisoners
which make up about 10% of the country's
prison population the main goal here is
to prevent people who leave prison from
committing crimes to go back in Viana a
first step at a rare showing of
bipartisanship Nancy thank you